let me ask you something um i'm i'll be
i'm used to
bumping into you sometimes i'll see you
in a restaurant uh
uh you're always uh i can tell you're
someone who's
um comfortable chatting with people how
are you dealing with this zoom
thing because it's problematic i agree
i mean i think and i'm sure we're going
to see some peer-reviewed studies coming
out about the
negative effects the cancer-causing
effects of staring
at a screen and talking to 10 people in
boxes all day long
i mean it is very it's it's funny
because it feels in a way
like it's it's it's distancing in a way
that
the the social distancing and there's
just this distancing theme that's
happening
and i know you know we're social
creatures and we we really want to
to come back together and be together
and and
and share space and all that but you
know obviously we're seeing the results
of doing that too soon
um and it's it's very challenging you
know we had
some people come over uh a family come
over and a friend of ours come over
and everybody was in the backyard and we
were all socially distanced and our one
friend
lives by himself and he was saying man i
really really needed this
and it's really tough i really feel for
people who don't have that
community and aren't able to actually
see people it's it's
it's really challenging right now yeah
the uh
i think sometimes i mean obviously zoom
is is a great
invention and it works for a bunch of
things and
for a show like the one i'm doing zoom
is necessary for all the late night
shows
but i sometimes would rather talk to
someone on the phone
then then zoom there's this obligation
now that everyone has to have a zoom and
sometimes there's 75 people on the zoom
yeah most of them and some of them are
like shirtless on an exercise bike and
if someone else is wearing a prom dress
and i don't know
it's all over the map well what i've
started to do
about zoom and and my wife was like oh
you bossed up on that one i like it i
just like turn the camera off
they're like dawn we can't see you i'm
like no you can't see me
that's the point of turning the camera
off i can still hear you
we're still good everything's gonna get
done but why do we people have to like
get dressed up and
feel like they have to on i hope you
didn't dress up
uh for me because you look good you got
the the shirt looks nice the hat is very
uh very cool is this just you hanging
around the house or was this you saying
i got to talk to conan
he's probably the biggest star in the
business i better clean up my act
yeah i yeah that that was it i got your
email
you're such a bad liar you just went
yeah yeah
that one
and he can't smell it just hand it to me